with trade negotiations between the
world's two biggest economies still a
work in progress
China's close and reliant neighbors are
feeling the impact on the outskirts of
Bangkok wrought upon lab sisa watt runs
a house where company started by his
father the medium-sized business is
heavily dependent on China factories
their supply raw materials wrought upon
uses to manufacture products for his
Thai customers the trade war is costing
him money but despite that he sees an
upside ha ha yeah I think this benefit
to be made China may have all the
material that I need but here we have
skilled labour who know the art and
craft we can export our products without
going through China or worry about the
trade war in one high-profile case
Thailand has actually one new business
as a result of Chinese tariffs on US
goods u.s. motorcycle giant
harley-davidson announced that it's
moving the manufacturing of its China
bound bikes from the u.s. to Thailand by
the end of the year this to avoid
tariffs levied on imports of American
vehicles the company had actually opened
a factory in Thailand before the trade
war to supply the growing East Asia
market but an economic adviser to Ana
Thailand's largest companies warns of a
threat not just to Thailand but to the
global supply chain if China and the US
can't settle their differences soon if
cleared walk going to last longer
they're going to have the long lasting
chanting of the dalish and other
supplies in popularity for the big
country like China he seemed to me that
China are now going to be may become
more internal internal rice that economy
that means China will rely less on
neighboring countries for materials and
goods producing more of its own that be
bad news for countries like Thailand its
largest export market is China the
economy here relies heavily on its big
neighbor to the north so businesses
could be forced to recalibrate their
supply chains scott hilar al Jazeera
Bangkok